when it comes to protests in belarus you
must have seen footage like this
or like this or like this
that was an infamous day as news junkies
around the world
stood shocked by the brutality of
belarus police
[Music]
this picture went viral at first many
assumed wrongly
the man on the ground was dead so what
happened that day
but well we found the officer who is in
this picture
and he told us his version of events
it turned out later he had a severe
alcohol and drug overdose we had the guy
when he felt really bad
but no matter how badly he behaved that
evening we tried to get him to the
ambulance which was a hundred meters
from us
he was unconscious he just laid down i
tried to wake him up
at once people standing not far from me
started screaming let him go let him go
i told them that i was trying to provide
medical assistance but they didn't hear
me
and screamed let him go i stood up
showed my hand saying i let him go
so what and he's still on the ground and
they don't know what to say
my colleague brought medics they helped
him right there and took him to the
hospital
the man turned out to be okay and went
on to become a media favorite
dishing out interviews
i don't know probably three maybe four
people surrounded me
my brother was there with me too it all
happened so fast
they just dragged me into the paddy
wagon one photograph
two very different accounts at first
glance it may look like a meme
something being made light of online but
in reality it's a metaphor of how
polarized the media wore over the
protests in belarus
has become anti-government demonstrators
enjoy the spotlight of outlets from
every continent in many languages
officers from the security forces are
telling me they feel that the world is
deaf to their words
like when their families and children
are getting death threats
we were facing how parents in
kindergarten taught their children such
phrases
your father is a murderer your father
beats people
and then the children come home and ask
their mother a question
mom is it true that our father is a
murderer how can you say this about a
man who protects his people
constitutional order and territorial
integrity
i asked them about all the videos
showing men in full riot gear severely
beating peaceful protesters
they say they aren't proud but insist
that the big picture matters
the use of force doesn't make us look
good especially if we use
force due to emotions we shouldn't do it
but it was that time when people came at
us with sticks and rocks
and we had to end that mess
people do not come to peaceful rallies
with molotov cocktails
with sticks and stones and they don't
try to run over military and internal
affairs officers with their cars
last sunday saw tens of thousands of
anti-government protesters making their
voices heard
peacefully from this legion no one was
arrested or detained
it seems there's finally a truce between
law enforcement and protesters
but a fragile one i'm being told it
seems both sides will need to keep their
emotions in check